honestly it's not a useful it's not  useful to riot it's not useful to break  things it's not useful to throw rocks at  people the idea that we're supposed to  correlate your level of outrage with a  certain level of justification in other  words the more outraged you are and the  more angry you are the more justified  you must be is absolute nonsense i think  that is  wrong saying that it's pointless to to  rally okay because there's power in  numbers and also when  people are getting in these groups  rather as  peaceful or not peaceful um  when these large gatherings are had  you're able to see at a larger tale like  oh what are what are they here for or  what are they doing versus it's just you  and i and we're like oh no don't do this  anymore no one's listening to us because  we're just two people  so i think that's senseless to say no  they look at the history  and the course of the different laws  that have been passed in america because  people have been rallying